j'accueille frédéric bourdin
[Musique]
en belgique je dis je m'appelais
wellpoint jimmy marines étaient au
luxembourg
en suisse c'était manfred kets troublant
une espagne mais à marco fernandes
italien soit nous alex gordon
billy beane génie ça les
[Musique]
crevettes
à waze nicholas moore
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
frédéric bourdin près du mans où il vit
avec son épouse et ses enfants on a
trois enfants nous souhaitons avoir
d'autres
on a des animaux ce que j'ai recherché
c'était un foyer un foyer qui pourrait
m'apporter ce que ma famille passé n'a
jamais été capable de me donnait ni les
services de protection de l'enfance qui
n'ont pas protégé je les trouvais tout
seul après avoir usurpé plus de 500
identité le caméléon comme on surnommait
se consacre désormais à sa vie de père
de famille oui même quand j'ai lu
travail je prends toujours du temps pour
m'occuper de mes enfants c'est
obligatoire nom
et son temps libre est dédiée à
l'animation de son blog
l'outil blog je fais des vidéos
donnent des opinions à peu près sur tout
et sur rien
tout ce qui me semble injuste et puis je
le dis clairement ce que moi je pense
que frédéric bourdin pense qu'il a envie
voilà c'est ma liberté près de cinq ans
après sa sortie de prison frédéric
appliquer sa dette mais laisse encore
quelques pourboires je vais travailler
dans un chrs au mans comme surveillant
et puis malheureusement pour moi
il y avait un incident là bas j'ai dû
déclarer un accident de travail mais
j'ai pas prêt d'arrêt de travail
quelques jours après que cela soit
arrivé j'ai reçu un message sur mon
portable
la part du directeur et qui je
m'entendais très bien qu'ils me
demandent donc de qu'il a besoin de
parler et l'a donc vu qu'il ya aucun
aucune raison de donner je vais voir mon
épouse je lui dis tu sais quoi je suis
sûr qu'il va me virer parce qu'ils ont
quelqu'un a dit qu'ils étaient
pour frédéric la route vers la
rédemption est longue aussi long que le
chemin pour oublier ses traumatismes
nous allons à sainte suzanne à sainte
suzanne qui est une cité médiévale très
jolie touristique
[Musique]
j'accorde
une importance
indispensable à ce que ce qui fait
plaisir à ma femme et mes enfants j'aime
sacrifier pour ma femme et mes enfants
et c'est à partir de là le mariage que
moi c'est ça le mariage et avoir des
enfants sait se sacrifier pour sa
famille c'est à dire faire qu'ils aient
tout ce qu'ils veulent la voir nous nous
retrouvons frédéric quelques jours plus
tard à paris en compagnie d'athéna la
petite fille aura son père rien que pour
elle pour découvrir la capitale
je ne la règle
tu vois pas menteuse menteuse marie se
dit n'importe quoi
au programme de cette journée culturelle
une visite au grand palais un instant
rare comme frédéric n'en a jamais
partagé avec ses parents quand ils
étaient enfants
oui comment ces grands il est trop gros
le ballon bonjour
groban
il en est tout en
bas il va faire la photo d'athéna devant
le ballon
yota pam à la promenade se poursuit dans
les beaux quartiers parisiens et face
aux luxueuses vitrines des boutiques de
l'avenue montaigne le repris de justice
s'offusque du matérialisme ambiant je
pense qu'ils accordent beaucoup trop
d'importance à des choses qui n'ont
absolument pas
c'est le
sait le monde capitaliste qui veut ça
c'est le fric gouverne tout là vraiment
je
veux dire ce monde me fait de la peine
c'est sûr ils m'ont fait parce que
l'amour là dedans ça n'existe pas il n'y
a pas d'amour ici frédéric bourdin
aurait-il enfin trouvé l'amour et la
sérénité dont il a toujours manqué
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
frédéric bourdin
jeunet avec bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde a parlé merci bonsoir
alors vous êtes né le 13 juin 1974 dans
la banlieue parisienne
oui votre maire ghislaine avait 17 ans à
votre naissance issu d'un milieu pauvre
sans vraiment d'éducation elle emballe
et de la margarine à la chaîne dans une
usine de nanterre
votre père qu'à six immigrés algériens
avaient à l'époque 25 ans alors qu'elle
était enceinte de trois mois votre mère
a appris que cas si votre père avait
déjà une femme et trois enfants en
algérie elle l'acquitté ainsi que l'
usine et elle a décidé de garder
l'enfant voilà vous résultats scandale
dans la famille son père à elle ne veut
pas d'un crew y comme petit fils votre
grand père maternel déclare elle refuse
d'avorter du [ __ ]
violent grenon oui oui
c'est un raciste fini il le sera jusqu'à
sa mort
maintenant tout ce que vous avez dit
concernant père ce qui a été écrit
malheureusement oui c'est un algérien
maintenant s'ils étaient mariés qu'ils
avaient des enfants ça c'est ma mère qui
le dit on ce même pas si mon père
s'appelait cassis maintenant moi quand
je les comme je lui ai demandé à maintes
reprises à elle et toutes les personnes
qui voulaient m'entendre des
renseignements sur mon père pour pouvoir
le retrouver
à la jamais été capable de me les donner
donc j'aimerais qu'on m'explique comment
elle pouvait savoir qu'il était qu'il
était marié avec des enfants
alors après cas si votre mère se met en
ménage avec ali qui la bat et là les
services sociaux vous placent sous la
garde de vos grands parents votre
grand-mère marc sleen va s'occuper de
vous elle vous emmène dans un petit
village près de nantes là vous retrouvez
profondément seule quoi vous êtes un
petit peu le paria du village à ce
moment là j'étais pas si seul que ça
malheureusement
j'avais aussi un oncle et une tante qui
ont déménagé avec nous
qu'ils étaient aussi les enfants mon
grand père ma tante
adorait dire aussi mais qu'est ce qu'il
fait là ce 6e sacre ouïe cette sale race
il peut pas crever j'entendais ça
pendant toute ma jeunesse et j'avais en
plus le voisin le voisin d'à côté qui
lui est bien le truc c'était les petits
garçons puisqu'il m'a violée
ça s'est passé un jour où on avait une
vieille télé noir et blanc
moi j'étais habitué à regarder dorothée
tous les tous les jours et la télé était
en panne et jambes était ma grand-mère
en le disant mais je veux voir dorothée
je vois redorait dorothée et on était
dans la petite cour devant la maison et
le voisin état est apparu comme par
magie avec un sachet de cacahuètes qui
est il a dit mais si vous voulez il peut
venir les voir chez moi moi j'ai un
mauvais je n'ai pas senti
voilà gt2 d'un caractère méfiant j'ai
pris le sachet de cacahuètes puis après
j'ai pesé le pour et le contre et je me
suis dit quitte à voir dorothée je vais
la voir chez le voisin j'ai été là-bas
ils allumaient brièvement la télévision
ensuite il a été pratiquement
immédiatement il m'a dit que tu as vu il
n'ya pas de dessin animé il m'a demandé
de le suivre en eau il m'a montré son
pénis il m'a demandé de voir le mien je
lui ai montré ensuite il m'a dit que ce
n'était pas suffisant il m'a déshabillée
cédé à billes on est allé au lit et là
bas il a fait ce qui ce qui était
affreux ensuite j'ai commencé à pleurer
il s'en est rendu compte il m'a dit
qu'il fallait que je dise rien à
personne il a essayé pas m'habiller
hilmar habillez moi il m'a raccompagné à
la porte je suis sorti j'ai couru voir
ma tante rennes qui est à qui j'explique
avec mes mots d'enfants ben ce qui
venait de faire hélas bien éclater de
rire au nez donc j'ai été voir ma grand
mère ma tante et six aides en même temps
expliqué ma grand mère a dit au raca
plus y retourner et voilà donc j'ai
passé ces années-là évités avait était
ce personnage j'avais j'avais 5 6 ans je
vois là donc je passais mon temps on
habitait la porte l'un à côté de l'autre
camp je descendais la petite rue et que
le voyait monter jeu prétextait avoir
oublié quelque chose j'avais envie de me
taire je me cassais dans l'autre sens
autant que je pouvais joint
alors c'est à cette époque dans ce petit
village que vous commencez à raconter
vos histoires mythomaniaque par exemple
expliqué que si votre père n'est jamais
là c'est parce qu'il est un agent secret
britannique bon ben vu que les arabes ce
n'était pas acceptable aux yeux de ma
famille fallait bien que je m'invente
être anglais voilà donc je m'inventais
ça et je dirais ça mes camarades oui à
l'époque vous raconter aussi que vous
désignez avec jackson j'ai découvert il
y avait quelques petites choses qu'on a
emménagé dans cette maison dont un 45
tours de michael jackson que je
m'écoutais à répétition et bien que je
parlais pas anglais à l'époque et bien
je vais répéter ce est vite devenu une
passion alors vous êtes un enfant
turbulent difficile oui déjà très
facétieux parce que quand la maîtresse à
aldo tournai vous changez votre voix
oui j'étais un petit peu le boute en
train de la classe j'étais un enfant
difficile c'est vrai
je je volais je pique elle goûtait d
autres camarades ou leur taille crayon
tout neuf
je faisait le pitre oui je j'étais je
faisais deux mois le centre du monde
dans cette école j'avais besoin
d'attention et
vous jouez à vous perdre dans les bois
pour obliger les gendarmes à vous
ramener à la maison et vous maltraitez
votre grand-mère alors alors il faut
savoir une chose j'ai même ma grand-mère
plus que tout pour ma ma grand mère
c'était ma mère je je dormais avec elle
le soir parce que j'avais peur de dormir
tout seul
ma grand mère c'est s était tout pour
moi mais les autres personnes qui
vivaient avec ma grand mère un oncle et
plus tard son ami et des amis de mon
oncle eux la traitait comme de la merde
il lui soutirer de l'argent c'était une
femme qui était handicapée des jambes
qui ne kiki ceux qui se néglige est
beaucoup aussi mondes pouvait-elle être
elle avait de gros problèmes d'hygiène
des gros problèmes de santé alors moi
quand j'étais petit garçon j'étais
toujours fourré dans sa robe toujours à
essayer de degas de deux d'être protégé
par l mais à force quand vous voyez tout
ce qui est autour qui ne la respectent
pas eh ben j'ai fini par faire pareil je
la frappais pas mais je il mais je me
suis mis à l'insulter je me suis mis à
lui prendre de l'argent à lui envolé
même si j'avais pas besoin de lui envolé
de toute façon parce qu'elles cédaient à
tous les caprices c'est des choses que
je ne veux pas d'un que je ne me
pardonnerai jamais mais oui je les fais
voile alors à 12 ans et demi vous est
envoyé dans un foyer pour jeunes
vous allez passer comme ça de foyer en
foyer et en 1990 un nouveau foyer dont
vous évader très vite et c'est là que
vous mettez au point ce qui sera votre
technique vous appelez la police d'une
cabine en prétendant avoir trouvé un
adolescent britannique fugueurs prénommé
jimmy voilà oui oui j'aime et c'est vous
dire oui oui en fait ça s'est mis en
place par hasard parce que je suis
arrivé tard la nuit à paris en auto-stop
g
j'ai marché des heures et des heures
pendant la nuit paris sans rien trouvé à
part à par des gens peu fréquentables
et puis donc oui j'ai eu l'idée
d'appeler d'une cabine téléphonique la
police de me faire passer pour un
passant qui avait trouvé un jeune garçon
en détresse de 14 ans qui semblait être
d'origine anglaise et qui aurait besoin
d'assistance oui c'est comme ça que
c'est venu donc la police est venue m'a
emmené au poste appelé l'ambassade
l'ambassade leur a très vite dit que je
ne pouvais pas être anglais ouais donc
il va relier paris à l'époque nous
voulons le jeu je parlais anglais comme
un collégien qui était mauvais
et alors vous dites je rêvais qu'il
m'envoie en angleterre où j'ai toujours
imaginé que la vie était plus belle
qu'en france oui oui parce que mon grand
père disait que
les français avaient baissé leur froc
devant devant les allemands mais au
moins les anglais de leur avait tenu
tête donc je me disais que s'il y avait
un pays au monde qui pouvait faire qu'on
pouvait traîner cette lettre
l'angleterre alors à partir de là vous
sillonner la france puis l'europe
passant d'orphelinats en foyer d'accueil
ou en service psychiatrique d'ailleurs
on découvre que vous avez un coefficient
intellectuel de 139 à ce moment-là ce
qu'est ce qui est très élevé
effectivement toujours sous de fausses
identités et en vous transformant en
enfants c'est à dire que pareilles on
vous aviez des crèmes dépilatoires pour
éviter que on voit votre pilosité quoi
oui je mettais une casquette jeux des
jeux déguisait ma voix je me donnait
l'air d'un adolescent parce que tout ce
que je voulais c'est vrai mais on
s'occupe de moi alors vous goûter la
célébrité une première fois en jouant
l'enfant trouvé à auch vous avez un
papier qui vous est consacré dans la
dépêche du midi l'émission perdu de vue
parle de vous nouveau quart d'heure de
célébrité en 95 sur le plateau de tout
est possible sur tf1 l'émission de jean
marc morandini qui d'ailleurs vous garde
comme comme stagiaire après l'émission
et là vous vous présentez comme un
menteur professionnel en quête d'amour
et d'affection si votre éternel problème
en fait oui parce que il ya des tas de
personnes qui ont une enfance terrible
et malheureusement et bien ces gens
répercute sur les autres qu'ils ont subi
eux mêmes c'est à dire violent enlève se
drogue devient alcoolique se suicide je
voulais pas ça moi tout ce que je
voulais c'était quand même tout ce que
je voulais c'était ce qu'on a jamais
donné une vie normale une vie avec des
parents avec des activités faire partie
de quelque chose faire partir fait faire
partie d'un groupe c'était tout ce que
je recherchais
à votre plus grande imposture c'est le
jour au lieu d'inventer un personnage
vous allez prendre l'identité d'un mort
celle de nicholas patrick barclay qui
avait disparu au texas le 13 juin 1994
séjour d'autres anniversaires oui du 13
juin chainel très juste c'est incroyable
oui surtout que le découvert qu'après
ouais alors pour sa voûte et nier les
cheveux vous fait tatouer le problème
c'est qu il avait d yeux bleus et vous
les yeux noirs et là bon toujours vous
raconter que vous avez été kidnappée par
un réseau pédophile de militaires
américains qui ont fait des expériences
sur vous on vous injectant des produits
dans les yeux voilà ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que la soeur
d'abord et ensuite la mère de ce
nicholas barclay vous reconnaissent
l'histoire tiendra trois mois elle est
venue elle a dit que c'était moi moi je
me suis sentie comme quelqu'un de
dégueulasse parce que j'ai eu vraiment
eu peur à un moment qu'elle est vraiment
cru que c'était moi mais il faut quand
même savoir que juste après elle est
assise elle est partie ce soir avec moi
dans un bureau elle m'a montré des
photos les photos de nos passes et enfin
de mon pseudo passé ouais et puis
ensuite devant le juge qui demandait
qu'une chose c'est être convaincu que
j'étais vraiment cette personne parce
que lui avait déjà des soupçons que
j'étais bien frédéric bourdin elle a dit
que j'avais jamais vu ces photos quand
le juge lui a demandé alors à lui a
menti pourquoi lui a menti plus tard
dans une espèce de brasserie à m'a
demandé qui j'étais si j'étais bien
nicolas donc je dis oui je suis bien
nicolas ensuite nous sommes allés donc
nous sommes allés avec l'ambassade à
l'hôtel à madrid parce que nous devions
prendre l'avion le lendemain et là j'ai
fait un choix difficile le choix est
difficile c'est que je me suis senti
redevable envers cette personne parce
que quand même avait évité la prison
premier temps donc j'ai fait le choix de
rester avec avec elle pour retourner aux
états unis je me suis j'ai vu
l'opportunité avec ce passeport avec cet
âge de 16 ans de pouvoir vraiment
reconstruire ma vie c'était idiot risque
est stupide mais je les fais alors ce
qui se passe effectivement c'est qu'il
ya un détective privé qui travaille pour
l'émission de télévision arte copie qui
lui a des doutes sur votre réelle
personnalité ensuite le fbi elle s'en
mêle et finalement la faire et est
éventé ce détective privé
c'est toujours a toujours dit qu'ils
avaient des doutes mais en fait il l'a
dit surtout après quand j'ai arrêté
quand
tout ce cinéma et effet quand les
émissions télé les articles alors là il
a dit oui j'ai eu des soupçons
la vérité c'est que il était convaincu
que j'étais nicolas barclay il apparaît
tellement tiré dessus il n'a pas arrêté
pour qu'une part pour la publicité c'est
tout lorsque vous apprendrez un soir où
ou la mère de nicholas barclays et ben
ouais c'est qu'en fait il ya quand même
eu des problèmes sur la disparition de
cette enfant on pense que c'est son aîné
qui l'a tué et qu'en fait quand vous
vous ont vu arriver c'était une sorte d'
aubaine pour eux j'avais discuté avec
l'enfant de la soeur c'est à dire le
neveu nicolas barclay il y avait tant de
14 15 ans à l'époque qui disaient que il
y avait déjà des policiers qui étaient
venus parce que des personnes avaient
dit qu'ils avaient déjà vu nicolas morts
ensuite il y avait plusieurs éléments on
voyait bien que la mer voyez bien que ce
n'était pas son fils je dirais le savez
je savais qu'elle s'avère elle savait
que je savais qu'elle savait donc voila
c'était c'était je vais pas dire le mot
jeu mais c'était un jeu de rôles mal
réglé donc oui un jour elle est revenue
complètement parce que bon l'été était
elle était sous l'emprise de drogue
toujours héroïne alcool haschich ce
qu'elle adorait voilà toute la famille
d'ailleurs et oui elle est revenue elle
a dit que c'est le diable qui qui
m'avait envoyé à l excès toujours
c'était bien histoire de nicolas de
pourrir sa vie et caetera et que oui
qu'elle savait que des zones n'avait tué
que c'est pourquoi est ce que je croyais
qu'il qu'elle n'avait jeter dehors et
qu'il avait été ouais voilà c
est quand vous découvrez ça vous le
saviez enfin je le savais déjà mais
que ce soit officiel net comme ça
j'aurais pu partir parce que je savais
que j'allais être arrêté j'aurais pu
partir le mexique t'es à côté j'aurais
pu rentrer en france j'aurais pu
inventer une histoire comme je savais le
faire
mais j'ai pas eu envie ouais j'ai eu
envie de rester parce que j'étais
écoeuré vous aller en taule oui oui je
suis allé en prison six en six ans
c'est cher c'est cher mais je m'en
plains pas j'ai j'ai pris toute chose
qui m'est arrivé comme une leçon est
jeune j'ai toujours assumé mes fautes
alors quatre mois après votre retour en
france vous récidivez vous fait passer
pour léo balley disparu en montagne
vous remettez ça avec un dénommé
francisco en ado espagnol au total vous
avez endossé 500 identité mais il y en a
que deux qui ont appartenu à quelqu'un
les autres sont des idées d identité que
j'ai créé et moi même inventé de toutes
pièces la seule famille que je n'ai
jamais trompé était la famille de
nicolas barclay et en fait je les ai pas
trompé mais bon ça restera comme ça
parce que j'ai fait six ans de prison
mais que ce soit l'autre famille de léo
balley à grenoble la gendarmerie les a
appelé une fois qu'il savait que je
n'étais pas leur fils alors a dit à
quelqu'un qui a essayé de se faire
passer pour votre enfant mais les autres
identités que ce soit francisco
hernandez fernandez tout ce qui est à
pau et tout le reste c'est des identités
que j'ai inventé et où je justement je
disais aux services sociaux aux
autorités la police le juge le procureur
que j'essayais de démontrer que ces
identités là était bien réel pour qu'on
s'occupe de moi ne l'était pas ouais
après ses derniers épisodes vous accédez
enfin une certaine célébrité il ya un
livre autobiographique qui sort il ya un
film qui démarre aux usa il ya deux
films en france qui ceux qui se font
quelles ont été vos rapports avec les
médias cette époque j'étais en prison
donc suite à l'épisode de grenoble gt4
mans en prison pendant que les autorités
étaient en train de se balader à travers
la france voir des gens que j'avais
connu pour voir si le fait que je
veuille devenir un enfant n'était pas un
prétexte pour approcher d'autres enfants
donc ils ont vérifié et puis
ils ont bien vu que c'était pas le cas
mais pendant ce temps là bas comme vous
l'avez dit les journalistes se sont
réveillés et donc faire un fameux
journal comme l'express ce journal
l'express a été passé un après-midi
entier avec mon grand-père et tout ce
qui leur a dit des conneries
faramineuses insurgés envoyaient je
faisais comme leonardo dicaprio
j'envoyais des cartes aux gendarmes pour
leur dire à à celle n'attrapez si vous
pouvez des choses tout à fait offensante
parce que jamais jamais je n'ai voulu me
moquer de qui que ce soit mais bref il
le rappelle il leur a raconté une salade
de choses pendant des heures et ils ont
tout imprimé sans vérifier donc mes
relations avec les médias suite à ça on
était assez compliqué parce qu'il ya des
sacs à merde qui écrivent n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi pour faire vendre ça fait
plaisir ça fait du chiffre et on s'en
fout de la réalité des choses donc plus
le temps a passé plus je suis devenu
sélectif avec qui je parlais il y en a
qui je ne parlerai plus jamais ils
peuvent me mettra millions sur la table
en promettant monts et merveilles je
m'en fous vous à gagner de l'argent à
l'époque avec ce livre ses films
si j'avais eu un agent comme beaucoup et
que j'avais négocié et que j'étais comme
ça que j'étais le vieux rapaces pourri
oui j'aurais gagné beaucoup plus
d'argent là je me suis contenté du
minimum ouais voilà mais j'ai surtout
demandé du liquide pourquoi parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais dans la rue j'avais
rien donc j'avais deux possibilités
rester dans un hôtel en attendant qu'une
équipe de télé m'appelle pour commencer
le documentaire qui à l'époque a été
fait en france ou alors elle va
recommencer faire ce que je fais puis
pareil attendent le même coup de fil
mais cette fois peut-être d'une prison
donc j'ai pris de l'argent pour pouvoir
survivre en attendant
quel était le meilleur moment de cette
époque
j'ai été
dans un foyer à palerme avait un grand
foyer un village d'enfants
avec des petites maisonnettes où il y
avait un éducateur un peu comme une
famille lévy la mjc
et puis là-bas il y avait un grand
terrain de foot on joue au foot on joue
au tennis on s'en foutait royalement qui
jettent est du moins on n'essayait pas
découvrir une identité j'étais vraiment
je faisais partie de quelque chose
j'étais vraiment heureux et je suis
resté là bas un mois le pire moment
le pire moment c'est quand il m'est
arrivé d'être dans les endroits où on
aimait et qu'on découvre qui je suis
parce qu'à force comprennent les
emprunter la photo et ben parfois les
policiers 20 font bien leur travail et
quand on a découvert que j'étais majeure
et ben ils m'ont dit au revoir et quand
vous êtes aimé que vous n'êtes pas tout
seul et que vous êtes vous êtes et que
vous vous retrouvez tout seul sur une
place à savoir que vous allez encore
devoir voyager de trois jours
pour pouvoir peut-être retrouver un bon
endroit une famille d'accueil à mon
foyer où vous allez pouvoir rester ça
c'est dur parce que vous perdez une fois
de plus tout l'amour que vous avez
réussi à voir vous êtes nostalgique de
cette époque oui d'une certaine façon
parce que j'ai énormément voyagé j'ai vu
le bon côté des gens j'ai vu des choses
absolument extraordinaire j'ai réussi à
survivre vous considérez que votre vie
n'était plus marrante à l'époque que
maintenant d'une certaine façon oui ceci
dit je n'échangerais à rien du tout
autre aujourd'hui l'époque qu'il en est
votre petite fille athéna oui tenait la
plus en plus âgés la voir son premier
enfant c'est quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel
ces enfants là
rien ne pourra jamais leur arrivée rien
parce que
la seule chose à laquelle je pourrai
jamais remercier ma famille
c'est de m'avoir appris être le
contraire de merde infâme 1 voilà tout
ce qu'ils m'ont fait subir tous les
niveaux tout ce qu'ils m'ont enseigné à
penser eh bien ça a été un grand vaccins
et jamais je ne serai comme jamais si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil je referais tout
parce que si jamais je ne faisais pas
tout je ne connaîtrai pas ma femme je ne
connais je n'aurais pas ces magnifiques
enfants donc même si je devais en perdre
un bras ou même en perdre la vie même si
je sais que je devais mourir demain
renversé par un train ou une mort
horrible je m'en fiche je veux dire je
ne ferai rien pour
pour supprimer la joie que ça a été pour
moi de connaître mon épouse est de faire
ces enfants là le jour vous allez mourir
sous les coups remarques sur vos tombes
à mes enfants et ma femme que je fais
aimerait toujours toujours et toujours
et que je n'ai aucun regret de ce
côté-là et aux autres que je les emmerde
merci frédéric c'est très heureux de
rallumer la lumière sur vous merci je
vous en prie et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux